Continuing on,
let's read the csv file for SPY.
In dfSPY, a temporary DataFrame.
The next step is the heart of
building the final DataFrame.
We combine the empty DataFrame, df1,
with the temporary DataFrame, dfSPY.
We use the join function of
the DataFrame for this purpose.
Let's do it.
DataFrame.join does
a left join by default.
So if we write a.join b,
it will read in all the rules from a,
but only those rules from b whose
index values are present in a's index.
For the remaining rows, that is
the index values, not present in b,
pandas introduce nans.
So in this case, all the rules from
the df1 will be retained and we will get
all the values for the prizes from dfSPY
for the given range we defined above.
So in our case, all the rules
from the df1 will be retained and
only those rules of dfSPY, which is
present in df1, will be retained.
This will give us all the prices for
the stock SPY in the defined date range.
Let's use join df1 one after
the join step to make it clear.
You should expect to see all
the values of SPY for the given dates.
Observe the output.
We did not get any
values from the dfSpy.
What do you think?
What could be the reason?
Let's print dfSPY to investigate.
Commenting out the join lines.
So let's see what dfSPY has.
We told pandas to join df1, and dfSPY.
But dfSPY has an index of integers,
which is not the same as
the dates index that df1 uses.
We fix this by informing
the read_csv function,
that the date column in the csv
file should be used as index.
We do this by using
the index_col parameter.
Make sure you give
the correct column name.
We also want the dates present in
the DataFrame to be converted into date
time index objects.
This can be done by setting the value
for the parse_dates parameter to True.
Let's see if this works.
Notice that the Date column is
now being used as the index.
There is no separate
integer index on the left.
Now let's see what the resulting
join DataFrame looks like
by uncommenting these lines.
But before that, let's add some more
parameters to the read_csv function.
Note that we are interested in just
two columns, which is the Date and
the Adj Close.
We can get rid of the other column,
by using the usecols
parameter of the read_csv.
We pass a list of column name we
are interested in, which are Date and
Adj Close.
Now let's see what's there in df1.
You see now we have just the Adj Close
for the SPY for a given date range.
Also observe that weekend
dates have NaN value.
Before we go ahead,
let's understand that csv NaN as string,
so we need to tell the read_csv that NaN
should be interpreted as not a number.
This is how you indicate it.
One last step.
We just want the date,
on which SPY traded, so
we can add more stocks
based on these dates.
Let's drop the rows where SPY is NaN.
For this, we use the dropna function.
df1.dropna will drop all the rows
which has NaN values for the SPY.
Let's go ahead and print this.
Now we have built a clean DataFrame
filled with SPY data using
a selected date range and keeping
only the dates that SPY traded on.